the holidays are upon us and most
businesses make more money in the last
month of the year than they do any other
month if you own a business or you work
for a business this is your opportunity
to capitalize and every one of these
presents I'm going to open up and give
you one holiday money making tactic that
you can take to the bank starting with
this one so let's open this guy up what
do we have inside we've got
diapers and we've got baby bottles now
what do these have to do with making
money inside of diapers and the baby
bottles is actually one of the strongest
concepts for Holiday marketing which is
something called a loss leader so what
is a loss leader a loss leader is
basically where you sell a very well
understood product and you sell it for
less than the market understands the
prices for so you sell it at a loss now
why would it be called a loss leader the
leader part of it is that it brings
people in the door most people know that
if you have a baby you got to buy
diapers the highest percentage of the
population you have babies buy diapers
they all need diapers sell the thing
that most of of them understand what the
price is for that almost all customers
will buy so that you can bring them in
the door because if you have the
cheapest diapers they're going to come
buy diapers from you now what they might
not know the prices for are all the
ancillary purchases they might make once
they come into your store whether that's
a digital store or a physical brick and
mortar store like these non-rip bottles
might have insane margins in markup
compared to the diapers and so trying to
make quarter or two quarters more on the
diapers compared to making dollars on
the baby bottles is where you can make
up what you lost here but you make it up
in significantly more profit and total
unit sold how do you use this for a
Black Friday or a holiday promotion what
you want to do is you want to look at
your product stack there you go this is
why I use an iPad so if I have my
services and so there's different
components to my services like for
example and I use Fitness a lot you have
access to a facility that's a component
you also have accountability which is
another component the actual workouts or
service with a trainer you could also
have nutrition meal prepping eating out
guides alcohol guide for the holidays so
there's lots of components to whatever
it is that you sell whether it's
services or products many people sell
something like this as a bundle and
there's nothing wrong with that makes it
harder for other people to compete with
you on price but if you take out one of
these pieces let's say this one's
accountability I guess and then I say
hey I'm going to make this 90% off
people going be like holy cow that's a
great deal and so what happens is you
can promote this 90% off thing which is
what a Black Friday or huge holiday
promo big bash would be like and you're
like well you don't just want
accountability right you probably also
want some help with your food you
probably want some workouts you probably
want access to the facility you probably
want these other things people like you
know what you're right I do kind of need
that stuff but the reason they came in
doesn't necessarily need to be the way
you make money and so that's the big
Theory or strategy behind loss lead and
I'm pretty sure diapers.com I think was
what it was called this was the strategy
they actually used to take over the baby
Market was they sold them cheaper than
everyone else did but they made all the
profit up on the other ancillary upsells
and so this works for product products
it works for services and it even works
for technology look at what you have put
it into an itemized list of all the
things you could potentially Market or
advertise and then you peel off one of
them I call it splintering your offer
and then you make an insane discount
around one of those pieces now ideally
even if you lose a little bit of money
on this you will make it up in the total
amount of leads and the reason it's so
important in general to have a promotion
going on during the holidays is the
thing I said at the very beginning most
businesses make more money in the last
month of the year and that's for two
reasons one because they advertise more
and two because people want want to
spend more so if people are buying
during that month then that's when you
want to be selling even more all right
so that's it with our loss
leaders now we have gift number
two gift cards what do gift cards have
to do with Black Friday and holiday
promotions first off gift cards are one
of the most lucrative things that you
can sell in general did you know that
Best Buy has an insanely low Redemption
rate so when grandma gets all the kids
Best Buy gift cards the percentage of
people who actually spend the money is
very low but essentially is is a loan
that a customer gives to a business and
the business just keeps the cash on
their balance sheet can earn interest on
it while they wait to redeem for it and
after a certain point of expiration they
can just keep all of the money without
even providing Goods unbelievably
profitable thing people literally give
you money for nothing not a bad idea but
how do we use this besides the way Best
Buy did to generate leads and I'll show
you how so I call this the gift card
strategy and this is one that I used all
the time my brick and Mort locations you
offer $200 gift cards to your services
one purchase worth of services so if you
give out massages or you have a
membership to a facility or you do
cleanings it doesn't really matter what
it is but one unit's worth you do that
dollar amount as a gift card that's
number one one
full
unit in in dollar amounts that's step
one the next step is that you Market to
your existing customer and you say hey
I'm selling this gift cards it's limit
two per person step three is you say
this is a $200 gift card but I'm selling
it for 90% off or 80% off whatever you
want I'm going to say 90 cuz I'm going
I'm going big here so your $200 gift
card is actually 20 bucks which is 90%
off remember we're trying to get
attention everyone else is doing Black
Friday promos and we need to break
through the noise and this is a crazy
good promotion but here's the catch
only as gifts for friends and family so
this is the ultimate stocking stuffer
you tell your entire client base they
can buy two these gifts for other people
and they get the credit for it being
$200 because it's a gift card so imagine
you open put a gift and says $200 on it
you're stoked the fact that Grandma went
to Alex's gym and she only paid 20 for
it you don't know that nor do you really
care but this is the genius part of this
strategy number one this is an insane
promotion so you're going to get a lot
of attention and a lot of people are
going to want to buy it number two is
that you're actually going to get paid
money for selling these gift cards but
here's the secret all of this is new
customers and so what this basically
means is that you're going to get paid
to get new customers and you would
probably give the services away for free
anyways to get a customer but rather
than marketing and spending money to get
someone in the door to try your stuff
out you're going to get paid to do it
but not only that these are the highest
quality customers cuz they're referrals
and referrals Buy in higher rates stay
in higher rates and because they're
coming from somebody else they can
usually help assist them in kind of
onboarding and figuring out the app if
you need to check in for a facility or
whatever it is that you sell you get the
assist from the friends you can double a
client base cuz you can get every single
person to bring not one but two and the
reason we limited two per customer is
cuz it increases the perceived value you
could sell two units and make it 70% off
two units would be $400 and you give 70%
off which would be 60 bucks doesn't
matter you're getting paid to get new
customers and the highest quality source
and so one of the important details to
do with this is that when you make the
sale ask them who they're going to give
it to and get the contact information so
not only that you're actually going to
get these as lead so if for whatever
reason that person doesn't redeem it you
can follow up with the lead to bring
them in and because you'll have their
contact information you can do a
three-way intro with the customer who
bought it and the prospect but what else
can you do with this the gift card was
for $200 right well what if everybody
who comes in you have a sales console
with and you try and sell them all
$1,000 thing well now you take that
$200 you mark it off and you can turn
these into $800 sales and that's the
last step of this so big picture one
full unit $200 $400 whatever one unit or
whatever it is you sell is limit it in
some way two three people per person
make it 90% off 80% off so you get paid
for it limit it to referrals of friends
so they're not going to use it on
themselves so they bring you more
customers get the threeway introduction
so you get the leads and then when you
bring them in actually sit down them for
a sale and this is one of those great
things that you can use to immediately
attract tons of new customers at a
profit during the holidays when it's
hard to break through so that's enough
with that all right now we're going to
talk about ooh nice and heavy what's
inside of here I wonder what's in the
Wonder Ball I wonder what's inside it
what Wonders It may hold I wonder wonder
wonder what's in Wonder B ah it's
tickets so this strategy is about high
ticket so let me explain how this works
you look at what your services are and
think what would the ultimate version of
this be like 10 times or 50 times as
expensive as what I I normally charge
like a complete transformation this
works especially well with Services
which is what I'm focusing on you could
probably think of a version of this for
physical product if my normal client
load let's say at my business is I have
100 clients I can't manage more than
that then you say okay I'm going to
limit this promotion to 5% of my
customer base if you're a hair salon
person and you have this many customers
or your uh car productor of this many
customers it doesn't really matter but
you say this is how many I have and I'm
limiting it to this you say hey I'm
doing this personal program that you're
going to get more service this is the
10x to 50 or 100x of your normal price
with a massive scarcity so you limit it
to 5 to 10% of your customers I'd
recommend five if it's your first time
cuz you want to sell out that's the
point and then next year you can bump it
to 6% 7% let's say that you sell
normally a $200 thing well then you
would sell something that's between
$22,000 and $20,000 which sounds like a
huge price Gap and it is but the thing
is is that most customers are fractal
and so what that means is that it's 8020
20% of customers will spend five times
more than 80% and so when you do 5% it's
actually 8020 twice so you have the
remaining 20 that are the five time
Spenders and you do another 80/20 on
that that's the magic between 5% because
those customers are two standard
deviations Above the Rest of the group
and we capitalize on that by making a
product or a service package that people
like that want to buy because it's
scarce let's say you had 100 customers
and you sell five of them a $55,000
package you make $25,000 and if you're
used to making $10,000 a month or
$20,000 a month from your remaining
customer base you can literally double
your Revenue that month only by selling
5% of your customers a much more
expensive thing the key to making this
work you build lots of hype around it
before the holidays you advertise the
crap out of how scarce it is and you
talk about the minute it's going to go
live and you prepare people you say hey
have your credit cards ready be ready
for it because I'm going to drop it and
they're going to sell out immediately
and then when you do the moment you get
your first sale let everyone know four
left three left two left one left sold
out every time you do that you'll drive
even more fomo and more scarcity and
more purchases so that's the high ticket
High scarcity strategy let's open up our
next
gift so much fun we've got shirts not
only is there one shirt there's two
shirts in this package now how are we
going to do one shirt to get someone to
buy two shirts I'll tell you so this
strategy is called free with prepay buy
X get Y3 we're talking holiday season
we're talking Black Friday we're talking
special OCC the key to this is how
insane you make the free thing if you're
giving away your core service then what
you can do is think about what's the
highest margin service I have and
package that in a way that you can have
people prepaid to get x amount free if
it's services or buy X and get y free
and I'll tell you the first place I
learned this so there's a place in
Nashville I saw and I came back 10 years
later and it was still there and it had
expanded so I was like oh they must be
doing well and their entire window pane
said buy one get two free and it was
pairs of boots and I was like that's
wild so I went inside the store and I
was like huh I wonder how this works and
the boots were all 600 bucks now if
you're familiar with cowboy boots cowboy
boots probably run about $200 normally
so all they did was they tripled the
price for one pair and said buy one get
two free and they capitalized on the
fact that for them specifically there
was bachelorette parties and all the
girls come in it's like well I'll buy
one and then my friends will get two
free or whatever and ideally if you
really want this thing to crush you
actually give more away free than you
charge for so it's buy one get two free
it's not even just buy one t-shirt get a
second t-shirt free it's buy one t-shirt
get three t-shirts free but the thing is
is that for most products and services
you can increase the price of the one
and so if you want to have a level of
service that you haven't offered before
that you want to do specific for the
holidays or a product you want to come
out with this is the perfect time to do
it because no one has any comparison for
the pricing let's say normally I would
sell these shirts for five bucks a pot I
might say buy one shirt for $10 and get
two free free now what ended up
happening is that I got $10 and I sold
three shirts which is really just like a
30% discount not a huge deal but the
perception of how much more compelling
get one to get more free than what you
paid for is the thing that drives the
buying Behavior so I just gave you two
different physical products examples but
this is actually super deadly with
services but it can be abused and then
some people can become dependent on this
there are businesses that I have looked
at in order to invest and decided not to
invest because they were too dependent
on this because it's such a strong
strategy and the reason it's so strong
is because there's all the cash is front
loaded so normally if let's say you have
a recurring membership of some kind
that's $100 per month that means it's
going to take you a year to get $1,200
but if you say hey I'll give you the
year for $600 one time that's a crazy
discount here's the key if you're really
expensive for whatever it is that you
sell they have to prepay it they can't
lock in the price and then say can I
make a payment plan on your discounted
services like no it doesn't work that
way that's the normal price if that's
what you want with any of these things
if you want to make sure sure that you
limit downside if you are worried about
too many people quote taking advantage
of it you can drive even more scarcity
by limiting quantity for most holiday
promotions I'd recommend doing anyways
because one you can just get your
immediate shot you don't risk the
business and you can take some cash off
the table that you can buy your own
Christmas Rees with this one I've even
seen work really effectively as a grand
opening strategy even though we're
talking about holidays but if you wanted
to cash flow the opening of a facility
so that you could cover all the costs of
the place without even having to take
Capital out of your pocket you just say
hey for the first 50 people who sign up
as patients at my chiropractor clinic or
my first 50 patients at my dental clinic
or my first 50 whatevers you just say
cool if you buy Six I'll give you six
and they're like holy cow what a deal
now again you control the price and you
can control the service and this is a
key part let's say we want to have this
$100 a month as our standard service so
what we'll do is we can bump this price
let's say to $200 a month for this
promotion pause don't think I'm doing
something ethical let me explain you
then add in one to two things you
wouldn't normally do with the main
service that don't cost you a lot but is
enough to differentiate the offers so
that if someone else later comes in is
paying $100 a month this person doesn't
get upset because you can clearly say
well that person doesn't get these
things that you get and they're like oh
that's the reason why and so if you're
going to use this promotion if you're
already in business come up with a
service level that you already have add
one to two things you can increase the
price and then do buy Six get six or buy
four get eight and you can drive an
insane amount of cash and purchases in a
short window and then you can limit it
by saying no more than x can buy and
it's one of the strongest promotions
that you can run any time of the year
but specifically during the holidays it
crushes so that's our buy X get y free
now let's talk about the final thing
which is the wrapping paper itself so we
gave four strategies on how you can
maximize how much dollars you make or in
the holidays let's see what present
number five
has so we've got a magic hat and a magic
wand now why is this relevant it's
actually more about the wrapping paper
itself because every one of the
strategies that I outlined is basically
a gift that you can deliver to your
customers and you can actually use them
year round but they're especially
powerful during the holidays but the key
is how you want to wrap it because let's
be real you're not going to change your
entire business for the holidays to make
something sound different but you can
make it look different based on how you
present it and that's where the magic
wrapping paper comes in I call it magic
because it's an acronym m is a magnetic
reason why all right this is key the
reason why we already have saw for us
because it's the holay all right the big
reason why is it's Black Friday and
everyone expects that but the rest of
the year you can still use the same
concept the second is the Avatar is that
you actually want to say who you're
targeting you don't want to just say
this is available for everyone you want
to say it's available for a local market
or for somebody of a certain age group
or someone has a certain interest any of
those things you want to call out so
they're like oh this is for me and then
they pay attention G is for goal is
what's the ultimate outcome you want the
person to experience what is the dream
that they Envision in their minds that
you want to say that you can help them
deliver through the gift that we're
wrapping with this wrapping paper the I
is for a time interval which basically
just says when is this person going to
get this goal or when are they going to
experience it and then C is something
that I call the container word I don't
have a fancy word for this I just know
that it has worked and it continues to
so this is when you say blueprint
accelerator program intensive whatever
right Launchpad like there's a million
different words that you can use to
bucket in all of the things that you're
trying to sell in one bundle if I wanted
to do something around stress right I
might say Avatar busy moms so we got our
Avatar check goal is
relaxation holidays is my reason why
interval 30 days and then this would be
getaway so just like that we can create
our busy mom's 30-day relaxation getaway
for the holidays boom and so if we're a
spa we put this together in the call out
for our promotion this becomes the
naming convention that we use around the
first four so this could be our reason
why we're doing a loss leader for the
diapers or that we are giving the gift
card or making it available is because
we want them to bring their other busy
mom friends or if we have a high ticket
thing then we say this is only for this
specific type of person which is why
only 5% of our audience can buy it
because it's the high scarcity High
ticket program or the reason we're
saying you can buy one and get two free
is because of these things and so this
magic wrapper allows you to give the
wrapping paper that we're going to put
on any of the first promotions to get
even more people to want to buy yours
compared to everyone else's and that's
all the money-making magic you need
during the
holidays